North Korea is showing further defiance
to the United States thousands of people
hit the streets yesterday to protest the
stiffer economic sanctions that the UN
approved last weekend Ben Tracy is
watching it all from Beijing Ben good
morning good morning so North Korea is
now using president Trump's fire and
fury comments as well as those new UN
sanctions to rally its own people and
that was on full display Wednesday in
North Korea's capital tens of thousands
of people packed the main square of
Pyongyang for a mass rally orchestrated
by the North Korean regime speaker said
the US will face a miserable and
wretched fate while marchers carried
signs that read let's become bullets and
bombs defending Kim jong-eun
this man said I will become the nuclear
warhead of ICBM to smash down the US
mainland the nest of Evo's North Korea
has now launched more than a dozen
missiles just this year and continues to
threaten to turn the capital of South
Korea into a sea of fire today South
Korea's defense Chiefs about strong
retaliation if North Korea continues to
provoke an unusual warning against mere
threats rather than an actual attack
Russia has now also weighed in and is
calling on the United States to remain
calm and not provoke North Korea to what
Russia calls dangerous actions what Ben
Tracy in Beijing for us Thank You Ben